in war it is always the children
always the children displaced always the
children disorientated
always the children without a say in
what adults are doing to their world
these children are on the move inside
ukraine trying to stay ahead of the
fighting here
many of them orphans most of them from
broken homes all of them with stories we
need to listen to
masha's school near the russian border
was bombed
it just crushed everything
in my town it's
a lot of crashed it's
some house like just fire
it's all so hard right now
because
i know it's just so hard
and vikas estranged parents are still
under shelling in eastern ukraine
her legs are trembling she says and
she's harming herself
but here to listen is psychotherapist
natalia orso
she too has fled the shelling and the
bombing but made sure even in war she's
reunited with the children she has cared
for for years
they are stressed by moving from their
home towns in awful conditions she says
they are worried about families the
instability and they feel alone
what i offer she says is support and
love they all need love so much love
i treat them as my own she said and i
stayed here to be with them
she then apologized for becoming upset
but there are a lot of tears here
talking and tears as the children of
ukraine struggle to understand what on
earth is going on in their country